good morning believe nation today's
message is be yourself over to you
Ashton Kutcher awake TV go you know I
think that if I could give young
Hollywood a suggestion it's to do
something that I never did which is have
the courage to stand up and say what you
believe and be responsible for your
actions now
a big part of growing up in this
business which in a lot of ways I did we
see you know you spent a lot of times to
just trying to be liked and you get
really worried about do people like what
I did people appreciate my work and
because that is your paycheck and and I
think that having the guts to just be
yourself sometimes is harder than people
think I think being yourself is the key
to everything great in life as an
entrepreneur as someone in business in
your career in your relationships you
have to be who you are and that best
version of who you are where so many
people are trapped in a world where
they're trying to be somebody else
you're trying to be the person your
girlfriend wants you to be you're trying
to be the person your parents want you
to be you're trying to be the person
your spouse wants you to be right you're
trying to be somebody else you're trying
to be the person your boss or your
customers want you to be where the only
real massive success is going to come
from you being you if you don't
otherwise is going to be untapped
potential always you could always be
better if you're living through your
parents filter and that's your life you
could always do something better you're
leaving tons of opportunity impact money
on the table for your entire life
because you weren't taking a chance on
being yourself and so when I talk about
this a lot of people in the entrepreneur
contacts say well I haven't how about
being in business I have to be who my
customers want me to be I have to give
them what they want to see right that's
how I make money and yes business comes
from providing value it's the most
important tenant in business right you
have to provide value to your customers
and they will pay you for that value but
to be able to provide the best value
it's going to be from you being yourself
and doing things that you are massively
passionate about and so success in
business comes from that circle of what
you love doing and combine it with
something that adds value to other
people's lives the overlap in there with
those two circles meet that's a big
opportunity for you it's not just
listening to customers taking their
feedback and doing something
you don't want to do it think about the
last time a customer asks you to do
something that you really really really
didn't want to do if that was happening
day in and day out you would stop
providing a great service if you're
spending your entire day doing crap that
you hate that is not the recipe to go
off and do something great look at my
youtube channel as an example right I
make videos that I'm passionate about
I'm talking about this subject because I
personally am passionate about it I feel
like I have a message in it hopefully
that's coming across in the tone of my
voice and in everything that's coming
out here all the top tens that we do all
the believe lives and the mentor me
series and everything that I put out I'm
deeply passionate about if I don't have
a message alongside if I didn't learn
from that video but I didn't take
something from it then I'm not going to
publish it there's a ton of videos that
never see the light of day on this
channel because I wasn't passionate
about it and that's important because
you guys could say hey I want you to
feature more of this kind of video or
this kind of video this kind of video if
I am NOT passionate and excited about it
then I'm not going to do it as an
example there's so much negativity in
the world right just look at the world
of politics right now with Clinton and
Trump and all the negativity that's
being spread out there and I'm Canadian
and I don't have a bias I'm allowed to
talk about it I could very easily make
videos talking about the top 10 reasons
why Hillary Clinton is wrong in the top
10 reasons why Donald Trump is wrong and
since people love negativity I'm sure we
get tons of people flowing to those
videos and we have the skills right my
team has the skills people to go out and
put those videos together and we can
match them up and make a new series and
I'm sure people would go and flock to
them but I'm not passionate about that I
don't want to put negative videos out
there it's not what I'm all about and so
that's not long-term success for me that
might help me get a quick hit that might
boost my subscribers would be bringing
the wrong people on board what I'm doing
is for life like in 50 years I want to
still be helping entrepreneurs this is
part of my lifelong mission I want to
create things that I'm proud out that I
want to share with people forever and
ever and ever I want this video to live
on I want the next generation or ten
generations down the road to see this in
you know a 3d model for
jected on the moon or whatever it is
because it's a powerful message that
will still hopefully apply the people's
lives and so yes you have to listen to
your customers but at the same time you
have to do something that is true to you
because as long as you're only living
your life according to the feedback of
other people and that's how you gain
your happiness then you're never ever
ever ever going to realize your full
potential Jason shaking his head you
want to come in and say something Jason
no way so the question of the day today
is are you really being yourself in your
business and what's holding you back
live in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press
0000